- Hello, good evening to the Silent Room.
My name is Bruno Vacetello,
I'm financial services partner
for IBM Consulting in Chile.
And here with me, Soledad Ovando.
Soledad Ovando is the General
Manager for Commercial Lending
at Banco Estado.
So to start, over the past few years,
we have all been talking about
artificial intelligence
and how it has moved
to the center of the
conversation in banking.
It's no longer just a concept.
It's been applied across
different areas in banking:
risk, compliance, customer engagement,
everywhere in banking.
It is in particular, this year,
where the adoption
accelerated significantly.
So that means that artificial intelligence
is a fundamental part
of the transformational plans for banking.
So far, many of the use
cases we are seeing right now
are mostly applied to
producing efficiencies
and incremental improvements.
According to a recent study
from the IBM Institute for Business Value,
one quarter of the
organizations are not using
artificial intelligence at the middle
of their intelligent workflows.
That means that they're avoiding
using artificial intelligence for growth,
for changing their
current business models.
As you can imagine, this is
a huge opportunity ahead.
And continuing with this study,
we are forecasting that
for the end of 2026,
intelligence workflows will
multiply by 12 in banking.
That will be, that's huge.
That will be a complete shift
in how the work is
being performed in banks
and how it will change
the customer interactions
of customers with the banks.
This kind of innovation
that is particularly important
in banking is regarding,
or it can leverage the richness
of the data the bank manages.
And as we'll take (stumbles
over words) advance
of the complexity of the current processes
that the bankings are now performing.
So this kind of innovations is part
of the soul of Banco Estado, and you know,
it's also part of the
story of collaboration we,
IBM and AWS, always try
to help with the gang.
So,
let me just give you a very
brief story of the past.
60 years ago, Chile was
facing, was undergoing,
a very important technological change.
By the end of 1969, IBM and Banco Estado
defined and deployed the first
tele-processing network in Chile.
That network allowed ranches
to perform transactions in real time.
That, my friends, was the
beginning of the innovation
and the modernization process
for the Chilean industry in banking.
Now, Banco Estado processes
more than 1 million transactions
per month on IBM technology.
You know, this history this epic,
is what we wanted to repeat last year.
So by the end of 2024,
we agreed a new statistical
alliance with Banco Estado
aiming to fulfill the
current Chilean needs
and being according to the current
technological possibilities
that we have nowadays.
And we set a particular goal.
Our goal is
to make technology and make innovations
available for helping the way
the Chilean client lives in Chile.
So before going further,
I would like Soledad to talk about
what Banco Estado is doing right now.
- Okay, thank you Bruno.
Good afternoon everyone.
I'd like to begin by
thanking Amazon Web Serve
for inviting me to be a part of this event
and especially IBM for inviting me
to talk about the work we
do at Banco Estado in Chile,
and our partnership for the development
of one of our resident innovation.
And apologize for my
limited English, which I,
why I will be giving my pitch,
my presentation in Spanish.
Isabel, help me. Yes?
(speaks in Spanish)
- [Isabel] Banco Estado
is 160-year-old bank
controlled by the Chilean government.
Its social mission is
bringing technology innovation
to customers and companies in Chile,
a key role in promoting
financial inclusion in Chile,
including universal debit
card, banking correspondence,
and microfinance programs.
Among the 20 million
people population in Chile,
17.5% of them, 17.5% million
hold one or more Banco Estado products.
Banco Estado app is the number
one in downloads in Chile
holding 12 million active users,
and 50% out of them use
the bank on a daily basis.
Banco Estado has 1.2 million
commercial clients that account
for more than 90% of the
total employers in Chile.
It makes it the leading mortgage
credit company in Chile.
(speaks in Spanish)
- [Isabel] Over the last years,
innovation has become a strategic pilot
to accelerate Banco
Estado business by pushing
the ecosystem model to raising
the bar for its services
and expanding its role
beyond daily banking.
Three strategic initiatives
are built around this priority.
Number one is digital customer experience,
both for helping educate
non-tech savvy customers
and to existing to the new generation.
Next one is the development acceleration
of a finance ecosystem,
managing the relationship
between large enterprises,
its providers, S&B, and end customers.
And finally,
to accelerate the sustainable
development of the country.
Some of the examples in the
strategic initiatives include
Rutpay, which will be the
first super app in Chile.
Startup financing program,
which in two years has
granted a hundred companies
plus $20 million in investments.
Impacto+ that articulates the
relationship between companies
and green impact for sustainability.
(speaks in Spanish)
- [Isabel] When the
innovation space was born,
the opportunity to collaborate
with IBM Consulting and AWS,
the main assumptions were
to build an ecosystem
coexisting with the existing
banking teams of developers.
It started with the strategic analysis
that led into accelerating a
housing construction ecosystem.
The decision for deciding if, how to,
when and why to invest on housing.
Number one was that Banco Estado
is the leader in mortgage loans in Chile.
It has a large percentage of investments
in financing, construction
and other housing initiatives.
And Banco Estado holds
a close relationship
with the government and large
companies in the industry
that helps accelerate the connection
between the actors in the ecosystem.
(speaks in Spanish)
- [Isabel] The housing
ecosystem joins banking
with companies and clients
and changes the experience
in purchasing real estate in Chile,
converging this and helping
Banco Estado become one bank.
This is a unique opportunity
among all banks in Chile.
There's no other platform as this one.
It merges IBM Consultings deep expertise
in financial services and AWS
state-of-the-art technology
to benefit clients in Chile.
- Thanks Soledad. Thanks Isabel.
And let me show you a
very, very short video
to understand what this means.
- [Narrator] Throughout its 170 years,
Banco Estado has continuously evolved
to improve its services,
(bright music)
serving its 15 million customers
and acting as an economic stabilizer.
Manual and complicated processes.
The disarticulation between
the actors in the sector
and limited access to
financing prevent many Chileans
from achieving the dream
of owning their home.
Banco Estado has a solution.
A digital platform that
allows you to search
for the best housing option at any time,
support savings, and
provides financial education.
and makes it easier to
obtain a mortgage online
within its marketplace.
(bright music continues)
Customers can apply for loans
online with the support of
an artificial intelligence-based assistant
that helps them throughout the process.
The platform is also designed
for companies in the sector
integrating the government,
real estate companies,
construction companies, notaries,
and product and services providers,
creating a unified experience
from obtaining construction permits
to housing administration.
Risk models based on machine
learning allow Banco Estado
to provide access to
housing to more Chileans
who are currently rejected
by traditional models,
positioning itself as a bank for all
and inviting them to join in
the development of an ecosystem
that supports growth,
innovation, and prosperity.
(bright music continues)
Together, Banco Estado and
IBM create a better future
for housing and construction in Chile.
Throughout its 100.
- Well, thank you, Soledad.
Let's look how the collaboration
is being put into practice.
So to address the different needs for the
construction and housing
players in this ecosystem,
we decided to build a new business model
and also a new operational
technological platform
that will be shared by all the
partners in this ecosystem.
So, all participants, banks, the notaries,
legal entities and other providers,
with access to this platform, will,
and they will be connected
by intelligent workflows
using artificial intelligence.
This approach promotes
collaboration, transparency,
and efficiency for the entire ecosystem.
And the fact becomes even clearer
when we look the client's perspective.
So,
what are we trying to deploy to the market
for the next couple of weeks?
A real change in the customer experience.
At the beginning, clients
will apply for a new mortgage,
we will apply for, will try
to search a new property,
and they will be assessed by agents.
They will help you
through the whole process.
After getting the approval,
agents will help the client in another
very, very, very complex part
with this process in Chile.
That means getting the documentation,
going through the processes
and then the closing stage.
Agents will help the client
just to accelerate that,
to prevent a lot of (stumbles
over words) interaction
and obviously get as fast as possible.
And after the sale,
we are also considering
a marketplace where
the providers with the different companies
interact with the clients
in order to get the offer
that the clients need,
put together the offer
that the clients need
in order to purchase services and goods.
This is one of the slides I like most
because it reflects the level of ambition
we set for this kind of process.
So first of all,
we are trying to reduce
by 15 days the total time
for mortgage approval and
processing at clientele.
We are also trying to reduce
the closing time in particular
after the processing of
the credit is being made
and that final stage where
everybody got stress.
So they want everybody,
the seller wants to get the
money as fast as possible.
The client was wants to get his house.
So we are making it 30% faster.
So as I mentioned before,
interactions will be key in
order to get these results.
We will reduce by health in interactions
between individual and business clients.
One very interesting
topic I definitely love.
We are considering for certain properties,
zero days, and disputes
for defined appraisals.
That means that for those properties,
appraisals will be made
instantly and automatically.
So this will change everything
in the local market.
So, and regarding the processing cost,
they will gradually
decline reaching around 30%
once the system is fully operational.
So
as we have mentioned before,
we made this new operational
model where Banco Estado
contributes with their unique
expertise in the local market,
knowing their customer,
knowing their products,
knowing their system at all.
And IBM shines to bring the
technological capabilities,
the operational capabilities, sorry,
that along with AWS
providing this infrastructure
help us put all together
and integrate processes,
business logics and data
in order to produce this concept
that we are starting to call
the online operative model for Agentic AI.
That will be a combination of forces,
of different services where
people and agents will interact.
And will help us foster the culture
that Banco Estado pursues
with our capabilities
in order to create new ways of working
for Chile and for the customers.
So, obviously that a great
part of this conception
and this implementation is allowed
by our very strong partnership with AWS.
Our partnership grew very rapidly
during the last four years.
We made huge steps every year.
And so it allow us to deploy,
to build and deploy very complex solutions
in just very quick time.
And also it help us to strength our teams
in advanced technologies.
And this is, we believe, that
this will get even better.
So right now we are awarded
with different prices
regarding our capabilities and Agentic AI,
our specific capabilities that we have
with AWS for financial services.
And also we were recognized
for our capabilities in
the consulting business.
Yes.
And obviously there is more to come here.
But,
but, we wanted,
we wanted, we really wanted to
make a special announcement,
maybe a couple of days earlier,
but I think this will be
the right time to do it.
Soledad.
- Finally, we invite the audience
to learn more about this initiative,
the new quarter of what is represent.
The housing platform will
be launched next week.
Check bancoestado.cl starting
December 9th.
- Ninth.
- Wait, no.
Can they keep a secret?
- Can you keep a secret?
You're asking if they can, what?
Will it stay in Vegas?
- Search in your browser
- Stays in Vegas.
- Casaverso.cl
What happens in Vegas stays in Vegas.
Thank you.
- Okay. Okay.
We are very proud of
having the opportunity
of announce it here, oh it's like,
it's a little bit weird announcement,
but we said it.
So, and obviously,
we've been talking a lot
and we were talking about
the complexity of building,
discovering, deploying
agentic AI nowadays,
in particular in financial services.
Now I would like to
introduce Vikram Murali,
Vikram Murali who will
talk a lot more about
what are the real needs
in terms of scaling,
in terms of managing efficiency,
and in terms of making
sustainable for the future.
So Vikram, thanks, and thank you all.
Have a good rest of day.
(people applauding)
- Thank you.
Can you guys hear me? Perfect.
There is no feedback,
so I think that's why
we keep taking the mic away.
So first of all, you
know, we all talk about
AI and agents and all of that, right?
So the first half of the presentation,
to me that's very, very important,
because we want to understand
from our customers,
from our clients, as to
how they're using AI,
how they're using agents,
what is the return of investment,
return on investment, right?
So that's a phenomenal story.
Thanks for sharing with us, Bruno.
So
once you talk about AI
and agentic frameworks
and agents, you create agents,
the next question becomes
how do you scale these agents?
How do you make sure that these agents
are cost effective when you run them?
And what we are seeing
from an IBM perspective
is our customers on AWS,
they are building more
agentic capabilities than ever
in the last, I would
say, probably 12 months.
The pace of adoption has
accelerated dramatically.
Now, when this happens
with any new technology,
when any new thing that comes in the field
we see a few issues.
So one of the first issues we see
is around the dynamic
nature of agentic AI.
And what I mean by that is, so imagine,
in place of agents if you had, you know,
an SRE doing some work
or a human doing a work,
there were predictive paths
that that human would've taken,
from run books and things like those.
But now with agentic AI,
it's really, really complex
and dynamic in the sense that
agents are, they can think
about various different paths
and you cannot predict
which path they will take.
And that's the whole
purpose of an agent, right?
They're autonomous,
they can take, you know,
they can think about different paths,
they can evaluate much
faster than humans can.
So there is much more complexity involved
in running these agents at scale.
So that's one of the first
problems that we see.
The second issue that we see is
the diverse infrastructures and tools
that these agents will have to connect to.
So in agentic AI, one of the things that,
I've had so many customer
conversations since morning,
one of the common theme that is coming up
is customers want to use agents,
clients want to use agents,
to take automated actions.
That's the whole point.
Now, how much do you trust an agent
from taking an automated action?
And if you have to take
an automated action,
you may have to give up control,
you may have to give
connectivity to agents
to multiple infrastructures.
The agent could be running on one cloud,
but the infrastructure and tools
that it needs to connect to
could be running on any cloud,
could be running on-prem.
So you have to give up that control.
So that's the second
biggest barrier that we see
is the diverse infrastructure and tools
that these agents will have to connect to.
The third area that we
see is the rapid change.
I mean, if you take a
week off, go on vacation,
go on a cruise and come back,
there'll be a new platform,
a new something to do with the agentic AI.
A new method to create agents,
to monitor agents, observe agents.
So this field is rapidly evolving
and we see customers struggling to adapt.
And if you look at traditional
development methods
and development practices,
there was a particular
rhythm in doing things.
Now that rhythm has completely
gone out the window.
So customers and clients and end users
have to rapidly evolve and change
when you talk about using agents
and then having these agents in production
and scaling them and so on and so forth.
So these are some of the areas we believe
customers are struggling with.
Now, what do you do about it?
To make agents really enterprise ready
we deal with large enterprises.
I mean, the previous example was a bank.
We deal with banks, financial
institutions, you know,
the insurance industry, so many
different large enterprises.
So to make sure agents are
truly enterprise ready,
the number one thing is
to make sure that you have
enough control and confidence
that these agents are reliable
and that they can be consistent.
They're always available and
they are scalable, right?
So these are main areas that
you need to concentrate on
when you're building and
deploying these agents.
The second area that we believe
that you need to concentrate on
is around performance and the value.
What is the ROI for when
you deploy these agents?
Now if something costs you
$10 and you're bringing
automation in and the automation
is going to cost you $20,
you can't do automation just
for the sake of doing it.
There needs to be an ROI.
So we always look at how
are these agents performing?
What is the cost of running these agents?
What is the save, the return on investment
that you're getting by going agentic.
And then how are these agents performing?
How much CPU GPU infrastructure
they're consuming?
All of these things
are very, very crucial.
And these are things which become day two,
day three items that
customers are, you know,
they don't look at it from day one.
So, let's assume everyone
knows how to build agents.
You know, you build your own agents,
you have a reason why
you want to build agents,
you want to deploy agents.
So let's skip that topic here.
What we are talking about is,
when you build these agents,
make sure that you think about
these day two activities.
You want to build agents in a framework
where you can observe them.
You need to know what is happening,
why is an agent behaving
in a particular way?
So you need to observe them.
So observability is key
when you talk about agentic AI.
The second area is optimizing.
So make sure these agents can run
in a particular optimized way,
not just with the workload with a POC,
with a proof of value
that you established,
but when you open the flood gates
and when hundreds and
thousands of customers come in,
these agents need to perform
exactly the same way.
So performance and scalability
are gonna be very, very important.
Now, automation.
So automation, again, like I said,
I had so many customer
meetings since morning.
Almost every client that I met,
the one thing that they're
looking at agentic AI,
is to help them with automation.
Some call it self-healing,
some call it automation,
some call it auto-remediation.
But at the end of the day,
how can you remove that human in the loop
or maybe reduce the human in the loop
to maybe a one-click approval, right?
Let the agent take that decision.
So for that, automation is key.
And the last area is govern.
Now just because you have these agents
and they're taking automated actions,
you need to have secure policies in place.
So we, as I said, we work with a lot
of large enterprise customers,
and there are control,
compliance control frameworks
in every region in the Americas,
in EMEA, in AP and so on.
And you need to make sure
that there are proper
governance controls and
policies set in place.
That way you can control
what these agents are doing.
Now if you look at IBM, we have,
I come from the IBM automation side,
I lead development for IBM automation,
and we have these
capabilities that we use both.
We take it to customers,
which helps them observe and
automate as well as, you know,
monitor these agents.
But we also use agents internally.
And the next few slides,
I'll go through how exactly we do these.
Now the first product that we have,
the offering that we have,
is called IBM Instana.
This is our answer to our
application performance monitoring tool.
Now, I don't look at agents
as something different.
Applications are going to be using agents
so which means we should be
able to monitor these agents
using the same APM tools.
We can't invent new tools to say,
you know, you're going to monitor agents,
so we have to use the exact same tools.
So Instana delivers
full stack observability
and with that it delivers
AI observability,
including agentic observability as well.
And one of the differences with Instana
and some of the other tools in the market
is that we collect data every second.
Now there are tools out
there that collect data
every five seconds or eight
seconds or 15 seconds, right?
But we collect data every single second.
We call look at metrics, events, logs,
everything that happens
around an agent every second.
So when it comes to root
cause analysis that there's
nothing better than this
particular offering here.
And by the way, everything that I'm gonna
walk you through the next few slides,
we use these within IBM
for our own products,
both in development and when
we run our products at scale
for our customers as well.
The second one is Turbonomic.
Now Turbonomic started
with cost optimization,
resource optimization.
Now if you dial back 3, 4,
5 years back when ChatGPT
came on and LLMs were the
big craze at that time,
everyone wanted GPUs.
At IBM, we did have a bunch of GPUs.
Every developer wanted
GPUs to go do whatever they
wanted to do with their ML training.
But one thing we found is that about
60% of GPUs were not even being utilized.
That's where Turbonomic came in.
We turned Turbonomic on on
our own development practices
within IBM and very quickly
we found that developers
were waiting in line because
GPUs were not available,
and they were assigned to developers
who were not even using them.
60% were wastage.
So Turbonomic is that
tool that can help you
from a resource optimization perspective.
We don't have infinite resources, right?
Capital is, you know, a
constant and it is limited
and we need to make sure that
whatever you're spending on
you really need to spend on
and it's not just sitting idle.
And especially cost becomes a huge problem
if you are developing on the cloud.
The next one is webMethods.
Now webMethods is a very interesting
offering that we have within IBM.
And what webMethods enables you to do
is it enables agents to run
in a secure governed area,
and the security and governance
is just not for agents.
webMethods is known for API
security and API governance,
that's where it started.
And we are extending that to
LLMs, Large Language Models,
and multiple enterprise assets.
And to us we see agents as one
of those enterprise assets.
Again, if you haven't
checked out webMethods,
it's our go-to answer from
a hybrid IPAs perspective.
So please go check it out.
It's the only way to make sure
that your agents are running
in a more secure and governed way.
Now, how do we improve operations
with agentic AI within our products?
Now it's not always
about telling customers
what they need to do, it's
about, within Instana,
if we look at Instana,
it's a product that has
been here for eight years.
So we constantly are looking
at within the product to see
how we can do code optimization
within the product.
Now one of the areas that we came up with,
this is called incident investigation.
So Instana is used for
root cause analysis.
When something happens,
we want to catch it,
we want to know why it
happened, that way we can avoid,
and Instana does learn from
it and we want to avoid it.
So this agent helps with
improving incident investigation
and it learns from it and it gets better,
and in most cases, it's
able to proactively tell you
this was the signature of the event
when it happened the previous time.
And when it is about to
happen it can tell you
"The same thing happened two weeks back
and it led to an outage.
Take action." Right?
So this is one way we are using it.
In our other offering called Concert,
we have an agent that helps with
auto compliance and resiliency.
Now compliance, we are not a GRC tool.
There are a dime a dozen out there,
But if you look at compliance
controls like NIST and SOC 2
and all of these other
compliance controls out there,
about 60% of these controls are not even,
you can't write a piece of
program to go evaluate it.
So how do you use agentic AI
to go through documentation?
One of my favorite
examples is a NIST control
called Media Control.
So if you are using
media, if you are on-prem,
if you're using a hard disk
drive or an SSD that goes bad,
your vendor like Dell or Intel or IBM
can't just come swap it out
and take the old hard drive.
You need to have a chain of command
to destroy that disc drive.
Now how do you prove that
with automation, right?
Those are the areas
that we are investing in
and this compliance and resilient agent,
it can help you with that.
So Gartner has, you know,
we are a leader in several
of these Gartner magic quadrants.
If you look at Instana from an application
performance management
observability perspective,
we are a leader in that quadrant.
CRN, we were a leader last year,
we were a finalist this year.
And same thing with some
of our other products,
API Connect and webMethods as well.
So each one of these products
can stand in its own right
and I think one of what I want
to leave this audience with
is anytime there is new
technology that comes out,
we don't want to come out and say,
"Forget about all the tools
that you used in the past.
We are gonna invent a new
set of tool chain for you
to go monitor, maintain, observe,
and make sure that these
can perform at scale."
We are not gonna be doing that.
So instead we were able
to extend our existing
tool sets and existing technologies
to go monitor your new technology as well.
Okay, so enough of listening from me,
I'm gonna bring my client panel up.
So I would like to welcome
and hear from our clients.
Ganesh Somaskandan is the
vice president of TSYS,
and Sagar Chikkala is
the CIO of Flexi Van.
Please join me on stage.
(audience applauds)
- How are you gentlemen doing?
- Doing good.
- Okay, so Sagar and Ganesh,
thank you for joining me today.
Now before we get into
AI and how you use it,
can you tell us a little
bit about your companies,
what they do, what business you are in,
and some of the challenges
that you have faced
in the last few years?
So let me start with you Ganesh.
- Thank you Vikram. Can you guys hear me?
Okay, perfect.
So yeah, I'm Ganesh Somaskandan.
I am from Global Payments.
So basically we are into
the issuing organization
where we takes care of the payments
in every lifecycle of the credit card.
It starts from you either
you apply for the credit card
or you swipe your card
in the PYS terminals.
It goes through the authorizations
and it becomes the transaction.
Or even when you go into the
phase of your self-management,
like an online banking
where you takes care of,
you do the card controls
or anything, you name it,
we offer the services for our clients,
which are like really high
critical mission clients.
The main factor what we are doing is like
we are obviously in the
modernization journey.
So with respect to that, we
have the hybrid platform,
which means we have the on-prem
and the big cloud presence with AWS.
So that's what like our
background is Vikram, yep.
- Thanks Vikram. Can you hear me?
Okay, so Flexi Van actually
a chassis leasing company.
I think before you
understand what a chassis,
I want to tell how imports comes, right?
Imagine we are getting
imports from Asia to US.
For example, it's going to Chicago.
When a ship arrives at the port,
the container discharge from the port
and has to go to the warehouse, right?
The container doesn't have wheels.
So it needs an equipment
which has a wheels,
which is called a chassis.
As you know, in the logistics
from a port to the warehouse,
you don't have the visibility
until it reaches the warehouse, right?
So that is where we
started a company called
American Intermodal in
2016, 10 years back,
with a smart chassis concept.
So we equip a chassis with
IoT devices like a GPS,
which gives the location, velocity.
We also have the mount sensor.
When a container is placed on the chassis,
it tells, and container actually
removed from the chassis,
it provides the state of the asset,
and we also have a weight sensor.
It provides what is the
weight of the container
on top of the chassis.
So with all these sensors
capturing the data
from the sensors and getting
the data from the customers,
the terminals, railroads, container yards,
getting all the contested data,
augmenting with the sensor data,
that's how we develop supply
chain visibility platform,
which we call AIM360.
It's very, very helpful
because with this one,
customers knows when
it started from a port,
when it's coming to a warehouse,
they know ETA when it's going to arrive
so they can plan accordingly, right?
It's not only giving the
real-time tracking and visibility,
it also provides network insights
because it generates a customer network
where it is actually stuck
in that particular journey.
How long it is dwelling
at a particular warehouse?
Where is the waste is in that network?
So we provide all those
insights to the customers
such that customers can use it
to reduce the cost of operations.
As you see the whole journey,
we scaled up thousands,
then went to the hundreds
thousands of assets.
As we increased the scale,
we ended up with so many integrations.
Integrations with the
customers, B2B integrations,
getting EDI, getting XML data,
integrations for the sensors,
integration with the API, the systems,
and we ended up is a really all these
integrations working as a silo.
It's really, really challenging.
That is where we migrated
all these integrations
into our integration backbone,
which is a webMethods.
- No, that is, thank you for sharing that.
You know, especially now we just went past
the Thanksgiving holiday last weekend
and then going into Christmas.
I'm sure from a logistics
perspective it's going to be,
you know, a nightmare if you don't have
insight into your operations, right?
And same thing with
Global Payments as well.
It's like, you know, customers nowadays,
if you look at the Apple card
and other cards that we are used to,
we expect everything to
happen instantaneously.
So, very insightful.
So one of the other
questions I had for you is,
maybe we start with you, Sagar.
So what has your company's
journey been with AI
and what do you see the future?
- Okay, I think we just
discussed the logistics, right?
It's always reactive.
I think most of you sometimes face the,
there's a flight delay.
when flight is delayed it
impacts the connective flight.
Same as when a ship is delayed.
Imagine it's coming from
Asia, it has to go to Chicago.
So it arrives, the ship arrives at the LA.
From LA to Chicago, it
might go on a train.
So when a ship is delayed,
it actually delays all
the connected conveyances.
So it's very important
to address the problem.
That is where we started our journey.
How can we make the reactive to proactive?
So we started a predictive logistics.
So, same problem.
Like you have assets
but there is no demand.
Where there is a demand, you
might have not have assets.
So there's a lot of network imbalance.
So to address this problem,
the predictive logistics,
we have so much of data,
billions of events based on
this GPS and all the sensors.
We train the data
and we are able to
develop a predictive model
which is going to actually
predict the velocity,
supply chain velocity.
It's going to predict how many
assets the customer needs it.
When a container comes,
if there is no chassis,
container cannot move, so
chassis is very, very important.
So we are able to predict how many chassis
for that customer needs
by location, by customer.
So that's how our journey started
with the predictor logistics.
Then, when you, when I
explain about the whole GPS
and we are able to derive
the whole container trip,
GPS provides a signature
of the trip, node to node,
but the main important thing is
the container and the
cargo inside the container.
So it's very important to connect
what is inside the
container to the chassis,
because sensors are on the chassis
which provides the GPS signature.
So to connect the
container to the chassis,
the data we are getting from
the ports is not enough.
So we install the cameras each locations
where we get the video feed.
Then we implemented AI vision.
YOLO model, we use that one.
So we have AI vision engine
to process those videos
to identify the object,
the OCR to derive what
is actual container ID
and what's the chassis ID.
Once we have the container
ID, we have the cargo inside,
then we provide the cargo
tracking in real time.
So that's how we went with the AI vision.
Then later as LLMs came,
then we started the journey with the LLM,
we implemented our own Flexi GPT
as an LLM on our own enterprise data.
We also expanded LLM to our portal
to provide LLM-based user experience.
So, typical any website when you go,
you click on a link or menus,
you provide the data, right?
But our portal actually based,
you can ask the questions,
"Where are my problems?
Where is my assets?"
Based on that, it actually
dynamically derive that UI.
Then we expanded our
journey to the agentic
because we have so much of manual, right?
Typical any business, when you look at it,
a lot of back office functionalities.
When you get invoice, processing invoice,
or getting the data, go to the websites,
then manually updating that one.
So we implemented EMCPs on
each legacy system we have it
because agent has to
connect to legacy system
to perform action.
So we actually build the MCP gateway
connecting to each legacy system,
and working with the agent to
execute the business process.
So all the journey, when you look at it,
data and integration is
very, very important.
It is the backbone.
Without data, there's no AI, right?
So the backbone for all our ecosystem
actually is webMethods.
- Oh that's, you know,
I keep thinking about my own household
when we go and order something on AWS.
We expect it to show up in
24 hours or less, right?
We don't understand the logistics
and everything that goes behind it.
So that's very insightful.
So what's your take?
- Yeah, definitely as I said that
the payments you mentioned about,
the holiday shopping and everything,
if I have to really share
the number of transactions
we just processed on the Cyber Monday,
it was like close to 1.5
billion transactions in a day.
Which means you see
how critical those are,
the applications, and from our
client commitment perspective
and also we know that even
if you miss five minutes,
you may lose the deal as a customer.
So, at the same time,
you need to have like a better
model in place and such as,
with the good observability.
That is critical for even though you have
your great functionalities
that you can offer,
if you don't have the good
scalability or reliability
and if you're not able
to react very quickly,
then you lose the customer,
you lose your credibility and everything.
So that's where our journey
with our observability started.
And I would say like even the you,
I know like Vikram, you
touched base about the Instana,
so we started using that
in our hybrid platform
because our is like, it's kind of like,
yes, we have the great
partnership with the AWS,
we have our APIs and other application
that runs in the cloud.
However, we have still
the on-prem presence
with the mainframe and the components.
With all this,
we are talking about
such a mission critical,
we need the complete
end-to-end observability
and not just from the static one.
So we want to make sure we have,
we are taking advantage
of every AI solutions
that we are getting through
the observability tools.
The one thing I would say
is like the auto healing,
that's really critical.
We don't want, using the example,
let's say like I just
go and set up the alarms
and I set it up, that's
not the job is done.
We want to make sure that
you identify the issues
and you don't want to be reactive always.
You want to be proactive
so you take care of the
AI automated based
observability so that you can
let this, let it itself heal the system.
There is no need to have,
that's where we are marching towards,
and that helped us really on the MTTR.
The other one I would say
is like the Turbonomics.
That's again, like the very critical,
because many companies,
we are in the process of
the modernization journey.
So the challenge is you need
to take care of your on-prem,
because you have the clients
and you have to move it into the cloud,
so that means you have to
take care of your cost.
And with the Turbonomics and
other things in the place,
that's where we can get
the more efficiencies
with respect to handling your processing.
You gave the classic example of the GPUs,
which are not used,
driven by the developers and other pieces.
So that's definitely where we
are marching towards on that.
Yep.
- No, thank you. Thank you for sharing.
My next question, and I'll
stick with you Ganesh.
So with everything
around AI and agentic AI,
like I don't know of a
single CIO or, you know,
a C-suite exec who doesn't have
AI on their roadmap, right?
They wanna do something,
which means there is a lot of
pressure within enterprises
to go do something with AI.
But then if you look at
downstream processes,
there are people who are very
reluctant to give up control.
They're afraid of security
and resilience and governance.
So how do you tackle that?
- Definitely, I think that's kind of like
a very common questions
we get from everyone,
including our customers and our clients.
Because there is always
a sensitivity about
when you put something in the
cloud, where is the security?
Or when you have the AI,
when you lose the control to the AI,
it's all at the mindset
and how we are actually
implementing and what is
the advantage by doing that?
It's not about we are
replacing the resource
or it's like we are just eliminating that.
The way we see it as,
it's kind of like you're bringing in
the quality of life to your
team, to your engineers,
because it's not really worth
for your engineering team
to spend time on the repetitive task.
Instead of that, they can
focus more on more innovation,
the more products which will
benefit the customer base
and the clients and as a company.
So that's one of the rhythm, we kind of,
we try to expand that to
across our organization
that name it as AI generation-based one.
It's about productivity you
spend focus on other things.
Yeah.
- I like the way you put it.
Improve the quality of your engineers.
I think that's one good
way to sell it. Yeah.
- Yeah, the technology is evolving, right?
You know, every day we see some product,
and as you see the export,
I see a lot of new products I see today.
So one of the important factor is,
we use the technology
to take advantage of it
and get some revenue, right,
or to reduce the cost.
Or sometimes we use the
technology because if I don't,
I will be left behind.
So I have to use it to show
the competitive advantage.
But I strongly believe that.
A use case with the ROI
dictates the innovation
not the other way.
So it's very important to
have the businesses case
to have a successful
implementation of any AI project.
- Well said.
I think I started to
hear more from clients
on that same thought.
They don't want to hear about
offerings or what they can do.
It's all about use cases.
So what is the use case and
how can you make my life better
with what you're proposing, right?
So I think that's good thought.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, sorry.
- I just want to talk about,
because when we think about
the risk and the speed,
there should be always a balance, right?
You look at our journey,
if you look at as the three
pillars of all our integrations,
one pillar is about all
the legacy B2B integration.
The second pillar is
about the API gateway,
and the third pillar is all about this
MCP, MCP gateway and AI gateway.
All these three pillars of the
integration are orchestrated
through IBM webMethods
Hybrid Control Plane
and providing a end-to-end visibility.
So we are actually migrating to that one.
I'm very, very excited about the product
and really kudos to the product team.
- Thank you. I'll convey that.
So thank you Ganesh and
Sagar for joining me today
and sharing your stories.
I think it's very powerful
to the audience. Thank you.
We do have a booth out here
that is the IBM Observability
Booth, the webMethods Booth,
and go check it out,
go check out our demos,
and if you have any questions,
feel free to stop by the booth
and talk to our technical folks there.
They'll be more than happy to
answer any questions you have.
Okay, thank you and have a good one.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, Vikram.
- Thank you.